[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y lima y continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
787.5 millones de dólares tendrá que
pagar la cadena de noticias Fox news a
la empresa dominion systems como parte
de un acuerdo para evitar un juicio por
difamación contra la cadena de noticias
dominion acusado a Fox de difundir
falsedades sobre sus productos tras los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020 en Estados Unidos
tenemos análisis
solo 15 minutos duró La tregua acordada
en Sudán entre el ejército y los
paramilitares de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido los combates continuaron y
Naciones Unidas estima al menos 270
fallecidos y unos 2000 heridos el máximo
responsable de la ayuda humanitaria de
la Unión Europea fue herido en
un tribunal de Moscú rechazó la
apelación de la defensa del corresponsal
de The Wall Street journal Evan Girls
covich acusado en Rusia de espionaje por
lo que mantuvo su prisión preventiva los
abogados podían cambiar la medida a
resto domiciliario Y ofrecían a cambio
pagar una multa de más de 600 mil
dólares
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en Estados Unidos porque la
cadena conservadora de noticias Fox
llegó a un acuerdo y pagará más de 787
millones de dólares a la empresa de
máquinas de votación dominion systems
evitando así el juicio por difamación
que podía enfrentar luego de que la
compañía acusara al medio de difundir
deliberadamente noticias falsas
impulsadas por Donald Trump sobre el
supuesto rol de sus máquinas en un
desmentido fraude electoral en los
comicios de 2020 para analizar esta
información conectamos con Manuel
Aguilera él es vicepresidente y
management editor de americano Miriam
Bienvenido a France 24 que implicaciones
o consecuencias tiene este acuerdo para
las partes qué tanto daño le habría
hecho a Fox ir a juicio
Bueno aquí se hace bueno el dicho de ese
que dice que más vale un mal acuerdo que
un buen pleito no yo creo que Fox ha
valorado los riesgos de acudir un juicio
en el que podrían no salir muy bien
parada la imagen de la cadena de
televisión y bueno al fin y al cabo de
alguna manera totalmente es un
reconocimiento de que no se obró bien de
que no se obró con de acuerdo a la
verdad y con ética periodística y yo
creo que eso es lo más importante para
la empresa demandante para dominion así
que yo creo que las dos partes salen
como decía con un buen acuerdo y sin
haber corrido el riesgo de ese juicio de
ese pleito público que hubiera sido
realmente Una vergüenza probablemente
para Fox no bueno dentro de Estados
Unidos la cadena tiene un público
bastante definido de alguna manera
reconocer que mintieron porque pues esto
fue parte del acuerdo les genera una
verdadera afectación
yo creo que para una parte del público
para esa parte de fieles a la que tú
comentas no porque realmente incluso con
todo esto Habrá gente todavía convencida
de que realmente hubo fraude con las
máquinas de votación hay un sector de la
población que es inconvencible Aunque la
realidad le demuestre lo contrario Pero
hay otro gran hay otro gran núcleo de
gente que está más en el centro a lo
mejor Incluso en la línea ideológica de
Fox centro derecha derecha pero que sí
que tiene una capacidad de análisis
mayor y que y que bueno que sí podría
castigar este tipo de comportamientos al
final los medios competimos unos con
otros y la credibilidad y la veracidad
es muy importante aparte de que es muy
importante digamos que distinguir entre
lo que es información y lo que es
opinión en este caso ni siquiera se
puede poner bajo el paraguas de la
opinión porque esto no no es cierto no
no se demostró que no era cierto que las
máquinas de votación hubieran estado
trucadas o que hubieran favorecido
alguna manera el partido demócrata
y justamente le pregunto se puede hablar
de decepción entre los sectores
demócratas tras este acuerdo porque
muchos querían que Fox fuera juzgado por
lo que califican como un ataque a la
democracia
por supuesto No yo creo que la que los
demócratas la izquierda estadounidense
quería escarnio público para Fox que al
fin y al cabo con todos sus virtudes y
sus defectos es una cadena conservadora
que siempre está atacando las posiciones
demócratas e izquierdistas entonces
Bueno en ese sentido se ha evitado ese
ese juicio público que hubiera sido
seguido por medios de Estados Unidos y
todo el mundo y que hubiera sacado
muchas como decía antes muchas
vergüenzas de estos tres presentadores
Que bueno que al fin y al cabo
inventaron no sabemos al final si a
sabiendas o no historias sobre sobre las
máquinas de votación de aquellas
elecciones No pues señora Aguilera usted
muchas gracias por su análisis por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
gracias a ustedes cambiamos de tema
porque en Sudán La tregua de 24 horas
acordada entre el ejército y los
militares de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido
duró sólo 15 minutos volvieron los
choques armados y en jartum el máximo
responsable de ayuda humanitaria de la
Unión Europea resultó herido las cifras
de Naciones Unidas confirman al menos
270 civiles muertos y más de 2.000
lesionados tras cuatro días de conflicto
Rafael Pérez nos amplía los detalles
el cielo de Cartoon se llenó de humo el
martes por la mañana los combates entre
facciones armadas rivales el ejército
nacional y el grupo paramilitar fuerza
de apoyo rápido FARC entraron en su
cuarto día mientras continúan los
enfrentamientos muchos habitantes
permanecen atrapados en sus casas
los bombardeos suelen empezar hacia las
cuatro de la madrugada y continúan
durante unas horas pero hoy no han
parado no sé si se oye de fondo pero
esta ha sido la historia de los últimos
cuatro días
Washington dijo que uno de sus convoyes
diplomáticos fue atacado Atrapado en
sobre el terreno la Unión Europea afirmó
que su embajador fue atacado en su
residencia los llamamientos
Internacionales han ido en aumento para
poner fin a las hostilidades Estados
Unidos y Egipto se presentan como
mediadores para resolver la crisis
estamos dispuestos a hablar con nuestros
hermanos de Sudán para alcanzar una
tregua y entablar negociaciones
eso sigue en pie nuestros contactos con
el ejército sudanés y las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido siguen en curso
un acuerdo de tregua de 24 horas con
mediación internacional debía entrar en
vigor a las 18 hora local pero los
disparos siguieron resonando en las
calles cuando llegó la hora cero la
situación se está volviendo crítica la
electricidad y el agua fueron cortadas
en algunas zonas y los alimentos
empiezan a escasear
las autoridades rusas rechazaron la
apelación del equipo legal del
periodista de The Wall Street journal
Evans covich con la que se buscaba que
el estadounidense pasara de prisión
preventiva condición en la que se
encuentra desde finales de marzo a
arresto domiciliario el dueño de Wall
Street journal dow Jones and Company
había ofrecido pagar más de 600 mil
dólares de fianzas y se daba la
liberación del reportero pero el
tribunal también lo rechazó el informe
es de Max Pérez Gallardo
una apelación rechazada un tribunal de
Moscú negro un recurso legal que
solicitaba la liberación del periodista
estadounidense
evanskovic que se encuentra en prisión
preventiva desde finales de marzo el
equipo legal de gearscovich compareció
ante los medios después de la audiencia
y expuso que a pesar de la negativa del
tribunal el periodista está listo para
aprobar su inocencia
tiene una actitud combativa está
dispuesto a luchar por un periodismo
independiente está dispuesto a
defenderse en la audiencia de hoy ha
dicho que está dispuesto a demostrar su
inocencia está resistiendo y agradece el
apoyo de todos
Qué es covich es acusado por las
autoridades rusas de espionaje un
señalamiento que tanto él como su
periódico El Wall Street journal y las
autoridades estadounidenses rechazan a
través de su embajada el gobierno
estadounidense se ha mantenido en
constante contacto con el periodista y
el lunes pasado la embajadora vin Tracy
pudo visitarlo en la cárcel Tracy
también reaccionó al fallo del tribunal
vamos a seguir prestando todo el apoyo
necesario a Evan y a su familia además
Esperamos que las autoridades rusas
sigan proporcionando acceso consular a
Evan los cargos contra Evans son
infundados y pedimos la federación rusa
que lo libere inmediatamente
desde el fin de la Guerra Fría
terscovich es el primer periodista
estadounidense acusado de espionaje por
Moscú el periodista de Wall Street
journal permanecerá tras las rejas hasta
el 29 de mayo esperando el inicio de su
juicio a seis meses del asesinato del
periodista colombiano Rafael Moreno sus
investigaciones salen a la luz un grupo
de 30 periodistas coordinados por
forbidden Stories siguió Las
investigaciones del comunicador en la
región de Córdoba al noroeste de
Colombia France 24 y se unieron a este
consorcio internacional el siguiente
informe les traemos un abrebocas de los
hallazgos de estas investigaciones
generadores de violencia el tema de
corrupción
trabajamos con tema de medio ambiente
nueve días después de esta llamada
Rafael Moreno fue asesinado en el
restaurante que acababa de abrir para
llegar a fin de mes
dejaba tres hijos pequeños
[Música]
impune como suele ocurrir en Colombia
cuando tú tocas esos temas y tú
denuncias esos temas pues lógicamente
los grupos al margen de la ley se van a
sentir ofendidos se van a sentir que le
tocaste a sus finanzas
y ha recibido amenazadas De qué grupo
armado Precisamente
en el territorio
me amenazaba a FARC y cuando estuvieron
los distintos paramilitares
ahora que está el cabo clan del Golfo me
ha amenazado
de la justicia
[Música]
me da miedo que pase lo que ha pasado
siempre
que al poder que la plata
que compren tanto
y uno con tanto dolor con tanta
impotencia
sus amigos lo veían con un periodista de
pueblo
su página de Facebook las voces de
Córdoba era seguida por más de 50.000
personas
Qué tal amigos yo Rafael Moreno critico
a las empresas basado en investigaciones
en trabajo de campo y en entrevistas a
las comunidades en otras noticias el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva convocó a una reunión en la que
participaron gobernadores miembros del
gabinete el poder judicial y alcaldes
para referirse a la violencia escolar
que ha escalado en el último año
solamente en abril han ocurrido cuatro
casos que se cobraron se curaron la vida
de cinco personas entre estudiantes y
docentes e hirieron a una docena la
propuesta de un sector es reforzar las
escuelas con unidades policiales
adicionales y es un asunto que genera
diferencias en Brasil Ramiro
cuevarberena nos cuenta más
los crecientes casos de violencia
escolar que han sucedido en Brasil
generaron preocupación en el territorio
una problemática que no era habitual en
el país sudamericano pero que solo en
este mes han sucedido cuatro casos
diferentes el presidente de Brasil ulá
Silva convocó a las autoridades de todos
los niveles para analizar La ola de
ataques de la que responsabilizó a
internet y a las compañías que hacen
culto a la violencia Armada
no vamos a convertir nuestras escuelas
en una prisión de máxima seguridad que
no tiene solución No hay dinero para eso
ni es políticamente correcto humanamente
correcto ni socialmente correcto si
Tratamos de hacer eso estamos dando una
demostración de que no servimos para
mucho porque no sabemos resolver el
verdadero problema
real sin embargo la propuesta que
elevaron algunos sectores sobre aumentar
la vigilancia policial en las escuelas
es un asunto que divide opiniones en
Brasil
es fundamental decir que las medidas
represivas el uso de la fuerza policial
no serán determina para reducir la
violencia escolar necesitamos trabajar
juntos para construir un ambiente sano y
una cultura de paz en la escuela y en el
ambiente escolar
y no interno
algunas personas critican tener Guardia
municipal Armada en las escuelas creo
que hay que abordar ese tema no solo en
la ciudad de cajamar sino también en el
estado de Sao Paulo vemos que la
sociedad está enferma de alguna manera y
esto permea el tema psicológico
en la reunión participaron miembros del
gabinete del Congreso el poder judicial
gobernadores y alcaldes y se
comprometieron a terminar con esta
crisis que ya ha dejado varios muertos y
heridos así llegamos al final de esta
emisión de directo a América aquí en
France 24 a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía y los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros que ya llega herminia Fernández
Con toda la información de nuestra red
de corresponsales en el mundo feliz
noche para todos
[Música]